الآن، حيث يواجه الأشخاص الذين طردوا من منازلهم
ويتعاملون مع الجوع والمرض
مشكلة جديدة، فقد
حولت الأمطار الغزيرة غزة إلى
فوضى موحلة، واضطر الآلاف من سكان غزة المشردين
إلى النوم في البرك
على الأرض في هذه الأثناء في
ساحة المعركة تسعة إسرائيليين  قُتل جنود
خلال عملية في شمال
غزة، إنها من بين أكبر
الخسائر الفردية للجنود في إسرائيل منذ
بدء الحملة البرية، دعنا نحضر CNS
Alex markart في تل أبيب بأحدث
أعني مشاهد الوحل هذه، أعني أن
الناس يمكنهم التعامل معها بشكل طبيعي ولكن  ليس
عندما ينامون
في الخارج، نعم أعني ماكس، إنه الشرق الأوسط،
قد يكون الجو دافئًا أثناء النهار ولكنه
بارد بالتأكيد في الليل وقد
شهدنا للتو مستويات غير عادية من
هطول الأمطار الليلة الماضية، وهي من أصعب
الأمطار التي رأيتها على الإطلاق  لم يسبق له مثيل
وكان من الصعب عدم التفكير أه أو
أو محاولة تخيل كيف يتأقلم هؤلاء مئات
الآلاف من الأشخاص أه أنتم
المسؤولون الإنسانيون تعتقدون أن
قطاع غزة بأكمله تقريبًا قد تم
تهجيره 1.9 مليون شخص من
إجمالي عدد السكان  2.2 لقد فر الكثير منهم
إلى الجزء الجنوبي من
قطاع غزة هربًا من ذلك
القتال العنيف أه ليس هناك ما يكفي من
المساعدات وعندما نرى شاحنات المساعدات هذه قادمة
رأينا أه غازين يحتشدون
فيها لأنهم يائسون للغاية  من أجل
الغذاء من أجل الماء من أجل الدواء أه من أجل
المأوى أه حذر المسؤولون الطبيون من
أن هذه أرض خصبة
للأوبئة وبعد ذلك فقط أضف
هذا الطقس الرهيب إلى المزيج
وكذلك تلك الملاجئ الرسمية التي
تديرها أه الأمم المتحدة وغيرها
تتزايد أعداد مجموعات الإغاثة، لذا
ينام الناس في الشوارع،
وينامون في أي
خيام مؤقتة يمكنهم صنعها، ومن
ثم تأتي هذه الفيضانات المفاجئة والأمطار
الغزيرة التي تجعل
الوضع أكثر بؤسًا  أه ماكس
أنت وأنا تحدثنا بالأمس عندما
كنت في معبر كيما شالوم وقد
سلط ذلك الضوء على حقيقة أن
جميع المساعدات لا تزال تأتي عبر
مصر وأن عنق الزجاجة هناك عند
معبر رفح يحد حقًا من
حجم المساعدات  يمكن أن يفوق ذلك
حقيقة أه أن هناك مثل هذه الفوضى على
الجانب الآخر، لذلك نرى الآن الولايات المتحدة
علنًا جدًا البيت الأبيض يتحدث علنًا
مباشرة إلى سي إن إن أه قائلاً إن إسرائيل
بحاجة إلى فتح معبر شالوم هذا الكيلو متر
في جنوب إسرائيل  للسماح بدخول المزيد من المساعدات
مباشرة إلى غزة ماكس